okay so getting into Batman death of the
family I guess new 52 Batman death of
the family keep in mind guys froze you
guys who are joining us for the very
first time anything marked new 52 comes
before DC rivers again I'll have it
before DC rebirth in the playlist so you
won't have to feel confused or don't
offer anything like that but death of
the family is probably one of the
greatest stories ever written in Batman
history to be honest with you guys I
absolutely love it because it really
changes the way review the Joker right
like this certainly speaking the Joker
depending on what area reading him has
always been the sort of comedic
sometimes even slapstick character I
mean that way he first showed up and in
DC Comics he was very violent very dark
but because of the comics code he had to
be made a little more funny now of
course he was returned to his darker
roots under Neal Adams I think it was
but while the time Steve Englehart came
around that basically gave us Batman the
Animated Series Joker and so then of
course we saw his character kind of wax
and wane over the years and in the days
really kind of like the years leading up
to the launch of a new 52 the Joker was
still very much the somewhat you know I
guess a great blend of like evil and
comedy but what this gives us here under
Scott Snyder is just a genuinely dark
and twisted Joker and the stories are
almost scary because of like how the
Joker is like it's almost terrifying you
know in a sense that Scott Snyder just
made him so fresh and so fun and so
interesting so um there are a couple of
things that I do want to point out here
for those of you guys were really
confused about Batman with regards to
like DC rebirth new 52 so on and so
forth there really is no classic Batman
which is to say Batman before the new 52
instead there's only new 52 Batman but
what DC did is they sort of doing things
like this and death of the family and
will start you know talk we'll talk
about these as we go through the story
but they basically started grabbing you
know comics and grabbing events from the
classic Batman era and rolling them in
and so that's one of the things that
kind of confused people about like the
stance of Batman the hard reboot that
sort of thing but the fact remains here
that with regards to the return of the
Joker this is twofold in Detective
Comics number one because what is this
whole thing starting with new 52 Batman
first started there was neither hide nor
hair of the Joker I mean he was just
kind of gone for a while the only
appearance he had was in Detective
Comics number one and that was in it was
like just it was your standard fare of
Joker storytelling it was the Joker who
was engaging in a scheme Batman was
chasing after him it was
cat mouse game the Joker was captured
and that was it but the story ended on
this very enigmatic kind of tone where
it seemed like the Joker's face was
basically removed and then we didn't
know what was going to happen after that
like we had no idea the Joker
effectively just vanished like that was
it the Joker was gone you know it so
because that fans were just kind of like
where's the Joker if we want the Joker
because the Joker is is consistently
ranked as the number one greatest
villain and comic books you know just
because of the fact that he's so crazy
if schemes are kind of nuts and he's
such an interesting character but with
regards to his return here this came in
a beautiful way so initially we just
kind of pick up with Commissioner Gordon
and Harvey Bullock and a few other
people in the Optoma City Police
Department nothing too major but the
power suddenly goes out now the backup
generators do come on but we get this
really eerie glimpse of the Joker just
standing in a hallway and that right
there really kind of hits to me as one
of the scariest things about the Joker
because it's scarier to me isn't like
the Joker copyrighting fish or it's
scarier to me than the Joker just going
on like a murder spree or anything like
that the fact that you would just like
the power would go down to a building
the generators would come on and you'd
look at the doorway and there would just
be this crazy guy with a hidden face
standing in the doorway that's just
terrifying to me what the Joker does is
he really just kind of like times Jim
Gordon and this is Scott Snyder saying
hey guys look this is the Joker that
we're getting now this is the Joker
you're going to see this is not the
crazy comedic Joker the wonders you see
from Batman the Animated Series this is
the dark sinister Joker this is the one
that you guys have always been wanting
to see the return to Batman number one
Joker the dark evil sadistic you know do
whatever it is that he wants to do kind
of version of his character and so if
the crazy thing is that as he's taunting
Jim Gordon he's going around and killing
cops all around Jim Gordon now this is
designed to really kind of be a
throwback of source to Killing Joke I
guess in the sense that during The
Killing Joke story Jim Gordon was put on
this rollercoaster of Terror and he was
made to view all these different images
of Barbara Gordon in a very vulnerable
state you know for the most part they
were naked images there was some
allusion to the idea that she had been
physically assaulted in multiple ways by
the Joker or the Joker's henchmen and
Jim Gordon was forced to look at these
different images as it was happening it
was very much a ride of absolute
insanity but it was the helplessness
that made that seem so you know
impactful in The Killing Joke and that's
what's happening here
Joker's walkin around in the pitch black
killing all these different cops under
the command of Jim Gordon and one he's
not quite paralyzed with fear but
there's nothing he can do to stop the
Joker because he can't find him he can't
see him and that's what makes being so
crazy is because once that man shows up
on the scene we don't really know
exactly how he got there but presumably
somebody did something or Bannon was
just kind of kind of patrolling or you
just notice the power went down at
Gotham Gotham City Police Department but
once Batman gets there of course the
more or less rescues Jim Gordon who's
clearly shaken by the ordeal but the
Joker had also stolen his face back now
at this point it's really just kind of
an exercise bye-bye Alfred and by Batman
could we just kind of figure out why the
Joker came back and that's one of the
things that makes his character so
interesting is because no one knows what
the schemes of the Joker are based on I
mean for God's sake he had a scheme
called The Laughing fish where he wanted
to make fish look like him and then
copyright them that was the scheme like
that that was it it's Joker storytelling
it's classic Joker stuff and that's what
makes him so cool is because no one
knows what he's going to do next now the
funny thing about this is Damian Wayne
has never really like encountered the
Joker in a tried-and-true fashion and so
while he's there watching the whole
investigation between Alfred and and
Bruce Wayne you know and while they're
you know Alfred Abruzzo just talking
about how dangerous the Joker is and how
they have to tread carefully and things
like that
Damian Wayne's ready to jump in
headstrong and I love this because I
feel like moments like this really kind
of give us that um you know that kind of
like yes the Joker is dangerous the
Joker is someone to be afraid of because
Batman's warning to Damian is do not
take the Joker lightly yes he's got no
powers whatsoever he does not have
super-strength it doesn't have super
speed any of that stuff but the fact
that you never know what he's going to
do is what makes him so dangerous nine
times out of ten if the Joker says he's
going to do something he's already done
it and he's just sending you on a
wild-goose chase case and point they
basically interrupt a broadcast made by
a guy you know where the Joker's just
headless guy tied down to a chair and
the Joker is acting like you know his
arms or the guy's arms or whatever you
know but what he basically says is that
Mayor Haiti is going to die
at midnight now this is not Scott Snyder
going through and just repeating the
past he is but he's doing it for a
reason when I was going to the story my
first thought was well this is just a
throwback to Batman number one right
like to the Joker's first appears I'm
going to kill the mayor at midnight you
know
that kind of thing ah that's not the
case instead what happened in originally
in Batman number one is the Joker was
going to kill the mayor in midnight but
it was because he had poison them 24
hours beforehand and this story it's a
lot more interesting it's a lot more
intriguing and it shows us how smart the
Joker is because remember when the Joker
first popped up he was just a guy who
dresses a clown and did crazy things
with regards to this what we end up
finding out is the Joker actually
poisoned mayor Haiti already but only
with half the solution necessary to kill
him and it's sense of what are you done
is he it basically just kind of like
poison the chemical that was used to mop
the mayor's floor and then you know dab
some chemical onto the clothing of the
various police officers who are guarding
mayor Haiti and so quite literally the
police killed the mayor in the sense
that when the two chemicals basically
merged the chemical on the clothing of
the of the cops and a chemical the
residue that's left over from the from
the floor when those converged together
it basically results in everybody losing
their minds everybody being exposed to a
version of the Joker toxin now this is
where Scott Snyder begins to turn the
story on its head because we look at the
Joker toxin and it's inherently and it's
always really been a toxin that kills
people with just this disgusting grin on
their face with this they die from
frowns and so it's really basically the
Joker going through and essentially
committing his own crimes but at the
same time doing it in such a way that is
just a little bit different from the way
it was before
now the reason why this matters and the
reason why this was significant is
because the Joker is key to
understanding the continuity of Batman
in the new 52 under normal circumstances
anybody would look at Batman and say
well he's just classic Batman and for
whatever reason made it into the new 52
not at all
what do you see did when Batman was
first launched in new 52 is they said ok
Superman gets a hard reboot he's totally
reset this is a brand new Superman none
of the things that happened in classic
DC happen in the new 52 we're just going
through his his stories for the very
first son the flash it was the same way
Wonder Woman it was the same way all
that stuff it was the exact same way
with Batman it was not what DC started
doing is they said okay let's grab
classic DC stories like The Killing Joke
and let's say it took place in the new
52 and let's grab classic stories like
nightfall and let's say it took place in
the new 52 it took place off panel and
we didn't see that story happen but it
simply just is the stories explained to
have taken place in the five years
between the time when Bruce Wayne first
put on the cloak and cow and the
day when his stories picked up and so we
were just kind of told somewhere along
the line The Killing Joke happened
somewhere along the line nightfall
happened and that's kind of the cool
thing here is because what we're also
told is that over the course of that
man's history his first encounter with
the Joker as Red Hood took place the
first time or I guess you know really
when they met and it led to Joker
falling into this vat of chemicals
surviving and then coming out with green
hair and bleached skin that that
happened these are the kind of things
that sort of just got rolled into his
new 52 by grabbing classic DC stories
and making them official continuity in
DC and so again with Batman basically
you know going through and deciphering
these chemicals that were used by the
Joker and figuring out the composition
spells out the words AC E ace chemical
once he gets there he actually finds out
of the Red Hood that he sees is not the
Joker instead of horses Harley Quinn
this is designed as a distraction to
remove Batman from the equation but we
end up finding out the reason this is
done is in order for the Joker to
basically kidnap Alfred Pennyworth now
anybody who knows anything about that
man comics will tell you that Alfred
Pennyworth is the one guy who's
off-limits I mean you do not touch out
for a penny right like like Alfred Mann
he's the bro you know alpha is the bro
you do not touch Alfred he's just one of
the coolest guys and so of course with
Alfred in danger with Batman effectively
figuring out what's going on pretty fast
and with what the Joker basically
leaving behind a tape that essentially
this kind of haunts Batman like yeah I
have you know Alfred and so on and so
forth it sends Bruce into this almost a
maddening state not in the sense that he
loses his mind but in the sense that for
him Alfred is the closest thing he has
to a father and to have this person
taken away by the Joker is like losing
his father all over again so it really
sort of speeds up the timeline it moves
things into a really endurance based
motion because in his mind it's only a
matter of time before the Joker kills
Alfred but the question is what happens
between now and the time that Halford
dies and that's what's the most
terrifying is because Batman has no
earthly clue what the Joker will do and
that's what makes the Joker so dangerous
with two faces he's probably just going
to kill you with penguin is probably
going to interrogate you for information
maybe ransom you or even probably you
know possibly kill you there's a handful
of options that any of those guys might
consider but the Joker is so insane
that there's no telling what it is that
he's going to do now of course from here
it's a matter of targeting Jim Gordon
and that's essentially what's happening
now something that I want you
keep in mind here is the way in which
Jim Gordon is poisoned he basically
receives a blood thinner at the hands of
the Joker and he just starts bleeding
out incredibly fast now the Joker did
that for a very particular reason and
we'll find that out here in a second and
again it really hits home at the idea of
the fact that the Joker is very
intelligent in terms of what he thinks
and in terms of what he does but
ultimately what ends up happening is
that man essentially traces the Joker's
location down to a local bridge and the
reason why is because of the fact that
this is another one of the crimes the
Joker had committed now this is Scott
Snyder essentially telling us this is
what the motivation of the Joker is that
historically speaking Batman and Joker
have just kind of gone round and round
and round and round and that was really
yet you know the Joker would escape from
Arkham Asylum he would commit some
crimes Batman were chasing that man
would catch him the Joker would be
arrested fill in Arkham Asylum and the
cycle would repeat that's just the way
the game was played but the funny thing
here is that the Joker more or less just
kind of reattaching his face with
strings even go so far as to taunt
Batman and say look this is the game we
play right I mean see the game that we
always play you know I go to a bridge
and I threatened to kill some people and
then you call in Nightwing and then
Nightwing saves a day and then you
defeat me and I go back to Arkham but
what if we didn't do that what if we
didn't play that game what if I just
basically killed them already what if I
decided to do that what if I took the
fun away from you now the crazy thing
about this is that Joker's entire scheme
here does have a method to his madness
and that's what makes this so visceral
that's what makes it so interesting is
that where he does just dead make the
bridge for the heck event and where
Batman's entire plan effectively just
kind of goes up in smoke the joker
effectively takes in captive and he
really just kind of takes Batman
prisoner you know exposes him to all
these different - the - the Joker toxin
you know and it sends the possibility or
I guess it makes it a possibility that
Batman is effectively poisoned by the
Joker himself now the other half of this
is the Joker starts to taunt Bruce with
the idea that he's like I know who you
are like I know what you're about I left
you my calling card you know he tardy
start he starts out referencing things
like the court of owls and so the Joker
was watching Batman in his whole court
of owls event he's been watching
everything happened the entire time you
know and he references things like The
Killing Joke he references things like
nightfall he references all these
scenarios he talks about Jim Gordon Oh
Jim Gordon Woodley
Ede for the city and that's why he gave
him a blood thinner was to basically
make him bleed for the city if Jim
Gordon wants to be a guy who's gonna put
his life on the line and bleed for the
city of Gotham then I will make it a
reality and that's what makes it so cool
it's because the Joker is basically
grabbing these metaphors of what people
stand for and taking them from the realm
of being a metaphor and making them
literal but at the end of the day
Joker's argument to Batman is that he
that Nightwing that Batgirl that you
know Jason Todd that Damian Wayne you
know they're all fake like none of them
are real none of them are who they
really are and this again really hits
home to the idea of The Killing Joke
all it ever takes is just one bad day
that this one bad day wouldn't
necessarily send somebody into the realm
of madness it would reveal their true
selves and that's what the Joker's
hitting out is this is not who you
really are this face that you put on the
face of Bruce Wayne the face of Dick
Grayson the face of Barbara Gordon the
faces that you wear at night is who you
really are you are Batman Dick Grayson
is Nightwing now something to notice
here is that he never references any of
them by name he's only just says I know
who you are but the bigger implication
here is that the Joker's kind of hitting
home at this idea that perhaps Batman
really is just an insane person that
perhaps Batman really is just crazy and
so again it's this really really cool
situation but maybe the Joker is not as
insane as he seems that maybe the Joker
is very much a completely sane person
but ultimately the Joker is able to make
his escape and the reason why is of
course the Gotham police department
shows up but Joker head was on henchmen
and Joker has those guys fire rockets
you know at the police cars and
incapacitate them and and that kind of
thing and makes his escape but what we
end up having here is Bruce Wayne waking
up in the Batcave to the other members
of the bat family to Red Hood to Red
Robin Tim Drake to Barbara Gordon bad
girl to Dick Grayson Nightwing and
Damian Wayne and this is really cool and
this is where the death of the family
concept begins to come into play because
essentially what happens here as Bruce
Wayne basically says somewhere along the
line the Joker accessed the Batcave I
don't know how he did it I don't know
exactly you know where or where he
gained his entry point but it seems to
have been done through me and what Bruce
does is he references this old instance
where he and the Joker were fighting on
top of a blimp
of course this is really kind of a
reference back to the older 1960s 1950s
Batman stories where the Joker was a
little more comedic but also a little
more sinister at the same time and
essentially what happened was a joke
was presumed to have been defeated by
Batman after having fallen off the blimp
you know most likely to his death but
this is Bruce also acknowledging his
lack of experience the idea that well
the Joker's defeated time to go home and
that's really yes and so of course you
know Batman had taken a route back to
the Batcave he tried to get some sleep
couldn't get any sleep at all came back
downstairs only to find that there was a
joker card laying in the Batcave in the
water and so of course again this is
cool because it's the Joker basically
saying I was here in the cave but even
then this goes back to the court of owls
right like it goes back to the whole
court of owls thing Bruce Wayne's like
no no the court of owls doesn't exist
because if it did I would have known
about it I would have discovered them
the fact that I know Gotham as well as I
do and the fact that I can't verify the
court of owls is real indicates to me
that they're not its Bruce Wayne's own
arrogance it's his own hubris that
always seems to get the better of and in
this scenario he's just like well it
probably stuck to like a boat or
something like that right like there's
no way the Joker would have gotten into
the Batcave because surely if the Joker
knew what our identities were he would
have targeted us individually but that
is what makes the Joker so dangerous is
because maybe he does know the identity
of Bruce Wayne maybe he does know the
identity of Dick Grayson and Barbara
Gordon and all these guys maybe he does
know who they truly are maybe he's been
watching them every step of their lives
for the last year and chose not to do
anything that's what makes him so
dangerous is because there's no way to
know for sure there's no way to know
with an absolute certainty and so what
happens is of course Batman's
investigations ultimately lead him back
to Arkham Asylum and this is really
Scott Snyder kind of hitting hitting
back at Grant Morrison's story Arkham a
serious house on Sirius
earth which between the storytelling and
the art that story is a descent into
absolute madness I mean that story is
insane if you ever get to read it
sometime I feel like that's the story
they would make schizophrenic screen
under the belief that it would cure them
like it's just it's almost like like
turn of the 20th century attempts to
cure a mental illness it's just one of
the most insane things that you're ever
going to see I couldn't begin to wrap my
head around like I had to put it down I
was like all right I am done here this
story is crazy as hell but from what I
understand if you finish it out all the
way it's an amazing story doesn't leave
hearing people keep telling me it's one
of the greatest stories ever told and I
feel like I should try to read it all
the way through but it's Batman makes
his way through Arkham Asylum the reason
why I say it's a serious hassle serious
earth or kind of a tribute to that is
because from what I did read through
serious house was severe sort it's like
a gauntlet right it's like Batman going
against a bunch of his rogues and
different things like that the inmates
of Arkham are essentially allowed to go
free Batman has to face off against them
all working its way all the way down to
the secret of why Perkins origin is
really like and it's very much the same
way in this story he's going against the
inmates of Arkham Asylum he's going
against some of the major criminals to
things penguin people who have allied
themselves with the Joker along the way
but as he gets through this he's of
course kind of forced to look at this
tapestry of experiences and this is why
I say this is where DC's are they
grabbing things from classic DC and
rolling them into the history of new 52
Batman the scene with a fisherman is
holding up the fish to Batman that's
from the Laughing fish the death of
Jason Todd these are all moments that
come from Batman's whole experience the
other various escapades that he's been a
part of in relation to the Joker as well
as his own stories and so again is DC
basically taking these classic DC
stories and saying these have now
happened in the new 52 they just
happened off panel we didn't see them
take place it has happened some time in
the past and so again after going
through these various guys these various
members of Arkham Asylum some of whom
were dressing as villains some of whom
are not ultimately comes across this
kind of really weird screwed up version
of the Justice League which is really
kind of crazy I mean it's essentially
just employees of Arkham who have no
families nobody would notice them
missing and wouldn't have any questions
as to why they're not there but this is
designed for the purpose of kind of
forcing Bruce Wayne's hand you know
Asuza Lee saying look you know each one
of these guys is going to try to pick up
the sword in the stone so to speak but
it's going to administer an electric
shock every time they do and it's going
to kill them so either you can go
through and you can sit in the chair you
know sit on the sit on your throne so to
speak and spare their lives or you can
watch as each one of them dies and so of
course ultimately Batman elects to sit
on the chair and that's really the end
of that he's you know more or less
electrocuted and knocked unconscious now
of course when he comes to he is
directly in you know this cave as it's
being held or I guess as he's being
being held by the Joker directly
this is the Joker being sadistic and
twisted this is the Joker basically
saying look these faces of the people
that you wear that's not who you really
are your face is Batman your face is
night when your face is Barbara Gordon
and symbolically he's literally cutting
their faces off and serving them to them
and that's the initial implication here
alfrid cutting banjo karai's essentially
you know having experienced exposure to
the Joker toxin but when these different
trays are opened up the idea seems to be
to the faces of Barbara Gordon Nightwing
Damian Wayne so on and so forth those
faces have all been cut off and they're
being served to them and so again it's
really twisted but it also falls in line
with a complete insanity of the Joker in
the sense that this does not make sense
to anybody but himself
it's just so dark and just so gruesome
now of course in the end Batman really
just kind of called it a day you know
we're all these different guys whether
they're effectively soaked with gasoline
there's Flint's under their chairs they
try to move it'll set the chairs on fire
and it'll basically burn them alive the
flame is thrown Joker intends to kill
them Batman knocks the Joker out of the
way and a fight ensues now of course
this also leads to Batman freeing out
your friend of arias members of that
family all of whom are exposed to the
Joker toxin once the Joker's too had a
cat explode and it is kind of crazy to
see because what this does is it shows
us their ability to overcome the Joker
toxin in the sense that it was really
more designed to kind of wreak havoc on
them as opposed to actually kill them
but at the same time the fight between
the Joker and Batman has some measure of
finality now it's not going to be as
final as like Batman in game right but
it still has some measure of finality
because what what Batman does if he
turns the tables on the Joker and that's
what makes it so interesting
Batman basically says you know You Know
Who I am and that's cool but I know who
you are I know what your name is now the
implication here in terms of how this
unfolds by Scott Snyder it really seems
to point at the idea that the Joker is a
very lonely human being right like the
Joker wants somebody else in his life
somebody as crazy as he is somebody that
views the world the same way he does
that the face of he wears is simply a
mask hence the reason he cut his face
off and had it reattached you know by
virtue of straining some staples that
he's trying to get Batman and Dick
Grayson I guess Batman and Nightwing and
his other members of the bat family to
be the same as him but with Batman
essentially confronting him and saying I
know what your name is I know who you're
under what your secret is it's almost
like it's this idea that the Joker wants
to stay crazy the Joker doesn't want to
know who he is now of course this is
going to hit home to the idea of endgame
and they kind of talk about that a
second because well refresh that once we
get to endgame the whole idea in the
Joker's mind is that he and Batman share
a relationship that nobody else will
have that is just part of what they do
they
go round and round and round and when
the Joker escaped Arkham he's called by
Batman and the cycle continues and
that's it that's their thing it's their
stick it's what they do this possibility
of Batman growing away from the Joker
this possibility of Batman walking away
from the Joker becoming something
greater than what the Joker considers
him to be could ultimately mean there
would be no more Joker Batman dichotomy
instead it would just be the Joker
running from a guy who's not chasing
after him anymore
and so again the Joker is effectively
trying to kind of twist Batman trying to
make him into somebody who's crazy
trying to make him question everything
about himself especially the possibility
that his identity might be out there but
ultimately the Joker is kind of like
falls off a cliff and that's basically
it I mean the indication here is that
the Joker is essentially dead that seems
to be what it is that happens where the
very lesion is kind of vanishes but of
course we know that he'll make his
return in endgame which is probably one
of the greatest stories that was ever
written by Scott Snyder with regards to
Batman but again what also happens is in
these last few pages of this story when
the rest of the bat family is free when
they're basically treated to overcome
their exposure to the Joker toxin Bruce
Wayne tells Alfred that he had
previously gone to Arkham Asylum under
the guise of making charitable
contributions when he confronted the
Joker after the Joker is supposedly left
his calling card and the bad Kings and
Bruce Wayne confronted the Joker with
the card and the Joker pretended like
like he had no idea the Joker gave off
the indication that he had no idea who
Bruce Wayne was but that's why this is
so important is because if all the Joker
cares about his Batman when the Joker
doesn't care about Bruce Wayne Bruce
Wayne's not relevant to him so long as
Bruce Wayne stays the Batman but that's
all he cares about that's all he wants
and so again it's really this idea that
it's all about the Joker reacting to who
it is that Bruce Wayne really is and in
his mind Bruce Wayne is really Batman
you know Bruce Wayne is not Reese Wayne
the philanthropist the billionaire
that's the face that's the costume the
actual person that's Batman and so
because that it's a really really cool
exploration into the mind of the Joker
to a degree in terms of how he views the
world around him but ultimately because
of the fact that that Batman simply
didn't reveal to the other members of
the bat family that the Joker had broken
in to to the Batcave the Joker had
accessed their identities seems to be
what really puts the nail in the coffin
of the bat family hence the name death
of the family because in their minds it
was an extreme betrayal of trust that
The Joker knew who they were
individually the Joker would just track
them all down he would destroy their
personal lives he would kill everybody
around them that they cared about that
they knew about and so again Batman
keeping this hidden meant then at the
end of the day he still didn't trust
each of these members of the bat family
despite everything they'd been through
all the fights they've been in all the
conflicts they'd worked on together
Batman still didn't trust who they were
and so it's really just kind of him
showing where he is what he's about and
for the most part everybody except Dick
Grayson really kind of leaves him
hanging and so anyway guys we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob port if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later
[Music]
[Applause]